Herr Professor Schall lassen Sie uns
gleich das Beispiel vom Eingang nehmen
Satellitenbilder die ausgewertet werden
um eine Lage einzuschätzen wie lange
braucht der Mensch und wie lange braucht
dafür die KI
die Frage ist nicht wie lange braucht
der Menschen wie lange braucht die KI
die KI ist in der Regel natürlich sehr
viel schneller sondern was kann die KI
sehen was vielleicht ein Mensch nicht
sehen kann ein Mensch hat Erfahrung hat
Hintergrund kann vielleicht auf Basis
von bisherigen Situationen Dinge
prognostizieren KI kann aufgrund der
Möglichkeit sehr unterschiedliche Daten
zusammenzunehmen andere Entscheidungen
treffen als Menschen das tun würden und
vor dem Hintergrund hat die Nutzung von
künstlicher Intelligenz ein
Überraschungsmoment das quasi demjenigen
der sie nutzt einen Vorteil geben kann
weil er zu taktischen Entscheidungen
kommt auf die ein Mensch vielleicht
nicht gekommen wäre insofern zweigeteilt
sie ist schneller und sie führt zu
anderen Entscheidungen ob sie dann
besser ist müsste man Simulationen
überprüfen aber sie hat einen Vorteil in
Überraschung nun fragt ihr ein User über
Youtube oder stellt zumindest fest dass
die KI nur so intelligent sein kann wie
die die sie programmieren
das ist ein ganz typischer Hinweis aber
es gibt ja ganz unterschiedliche Formen
von künstlicher Intelligenz und es gibt
künstliche Intelligenzen die anhand von
sozusagen Sensordaten real world Daten
trainiert werden das sind dann
typischerweise solche die mit neuronalen
Netzen arbeiten und dann gibt es solche
die Spielen gegen sich selbst spielen
auf Basis bestimmter Regeln das kennen
wir das kennen wir zum Beispiel aus go
alphago war ein schönes Beispiel dafür
und diese Form von künstliche
Intelligenz wird nicht programmiert
sondern man hat Lust die
Rahmenbedingungen und Situationen werden
so häufig
iteriert bis man zu
taktischen entscheidungssequenzen kommt
die gut sind und insofern ist das
Argument mit dem Programmieren geht
nicht für alle Kies sondern bloß für
bestimmte Kios und gerade diese sich
selbst anlernen denn spielenden Kios
sind sehr innovativ wir sind jetzt hier
gerade
ki-roboter im Einsatz sind
künstliche Intelligenzen die besseren
Soldaten oder möglicherweise die
besseren Generäle
interessante Frage weil was heißt hier
besser wir haben zum Glück die Genfer
Konvention unterzeichnet das heißt es
gibt bestimmte Grenzen dessen was wir
wollen und was wir tun dürfen und das
heißt gute Soldaten oder gute Generäle
sind diejenigen die sich an die Ethik
des Krieges halten wenn in der notwendig
ist das ist bei künstliche Intelligenz
nicht notwendigerweise der Fall also je
nachdem welche Grenzen die KI hat für
handeln kann sie besser oder schlechter
sein erster Punkt
zweiter Punkt ist das was wir von
menschlichem Handeln kennt dass man
Angst hat dass man
müde wird dass man vielleicht
entscheidungsmühle wird und ähnliches
das trifft natürlich auf künstliche
Intelligenz nicht zu und insofern gibt
es vielleicht auch bestimmte Entscheid
ungen die aufgrund von über Erschöpfung
oder ähnliches passieren dort auch nicht
also was sind die Parameter mit denen
sie bestimmen was ist ein guter oder ein
schlechter Soldat was ist eine gute oder
eine schlechte Entscheidung denn wir
sind nicht dort zu sagen jeder Sieg ist
ein guter Sieg unabhängig von Mitteln
die wir dafür einsetzen und vor dem
Hintergrund lassen uns über die Mittel
sprechen das was wir bereits sind
sozusagen zu geben über die Ethik und
dann fragen wir noch mal was kann KI
dazu leisten solche Ziele zu erreichen
ich freue mich darüber mit ihnen über
die Ethik zu sprechen sie sind auch
Philosoph und das sind ja auch viele
philosophische Fragen die da dahinter
stehen die man sich dann stellen muss
dazu an dieser Stelle noch ein Kommentar
von einem User Thomas Rabenstein sagt
über YouTube eine KI ist nicht schlecht
invasiv oder bösartig sondern sie ist so
wie wir sie erschaffen sie kann Leben
retten oder zerstören es liegt an uns
welchen Weg wir wählen ich würde gerne
die ethik-diskussion allerdings noch ein
bisschen nach nach hinten schieben
inhaltlich hier in unserem Stream
sondern erstmal darüber sprechen was KI
denn im Krieg in der Kriegsführung so
überhaupt alles kann und wie sie
eingesetzt wird können Sie da aktuell
ein paar Beispiele geben auch mit Blick
auf die Bundeswehr wo da schon KI im
Einsatz ist
ich würde ich würde sogar noch erweitern
und gleich quasi in Richtung Ukraine
schauen
es ist so dass so dass dort so wohl auf
ukrainischer wie auch auf russischer
Seite künstliche Intelligenz zum Einsatz
kommt wobei künstliche Intelligenz jetzt
für mich bedeutet jede Form der
algorithmischen Aufarbeitung von Daten
bei denen das Ergebnis so wirkt als wenn
ein Mensch klug handeln würde ja also
das als vor Definition und vor diesem
Hintergrund haben wir es in dem letzten
500 Tagen erlebt dass Systeme die zuvor
sagen diesmal analog waren digital
hochgerüstet oder aufgerüstet wurden und
damit wirkungs effektiver wurden
das bezieht sich jetzt auf
unterschiedliche Dinge das Drohnen quasi
KI nutzen quasi automatisch Ziele zu
finden zu identifizieren das wissen wir
dann sehr relevant für die Ukraine und
den die Entwicklung des Krieges dort ist
die Auswertung von intelligence
Informationen also von Bildmaterial von
abgehörten Funksprüchen oder ähnliches
das sind so viele Informationen das
können Menschen nicht machen dort kommt
künstliche Intelligenz natürlich zum
Zuge aber auch bei einer anderen Frage
nämlich bei Artillerie und
feuerleitsystemen kommt künstliche
Intelligenzen Zuge das heißt dort wo
früher zu Beginn des Krieges zwischen
einem Befehl und der Ausrichtung
vielleicht 30 Minuten vergingen Vergehen
jetzt mit Hilfe der Nutzung von
künstliche Intelligenz zwei drei Minuten
und sehr wichtig für die Ukraine das
solche künstlichen intelligenzsysteme
auch die Munition effizienter und
effektiver nutzen sehr wichtig das heißt
wir haben künstliche Intelligenz überall
sie ist
kein Game changer weil sie auf beiden
Seiten benutzt wird aber ein Game
Veränderer weil tatsächlich die Seite
die ist nicht nutzen würde meines
Erachtens relativ schnell verlieren
würde die Seite die sie nutzt aber nicht
notwendigerweise gewinnt
sie haben einige Beispiele genannt was
die Ukraine angeht zum Beispiel Drohnen
zum Beispiel die Munition
um den Ansatz von Munition ich möchte
gerne ein Beispiel noch herausgreifen
mit dem sie auch als forschender
beschäftigt sind denn es gibt eine Frage
dazu im Chat ein User fragt kann KI
schon für Kriegsszenarien sogenannte war
Games herangezogen werden um die
bestmögliche Taktik zu entwickeln und
wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe dann
ist Ihre Antwort darauf ja und sie heißt
ghostplay ja die Antwort lautet
tatsächlich Cosplay wir haben ein
Forschungsprojekt in dem eine KI der
dritten Welle genutzt wird um
drohnenschwärme also angreifen
für alle die dies nicht wissen die
dritte Welle können Sie die ganz kurz
erklären bitte das mache ich sehr gerne
zweite Welle KI ist so typischerweise
identifiziert mit Bilderkennung und
ähnlichem also quasi statische Dinge die
wiedererkannt werden musste Erkennung
KI der dritten Welle bedeutet dass man
Kontext sensitiv ist die KI reagiert auf
dem Kontext indem sie genutzt wird und
sie ist das wird ganz wichtig
sensitiv für die Konsequenzen über die
Zeit ich gebe ihnen kleines Beispiel es
könnte ja sein dass wir in diesem
Augenblick ein taktischen Vorteil haben
indem wir ein aktives Radar nutzen wir
sehen aber dass wenn wir das aktive
Radon nutzen die uns exponieren und dann
vielleicht diese Frage zerstört wird
wenn man sichtbar gemacht wird das heißt
man muss in die Tiefe gehen und schauen
wie unterschiedliche Handlungen auf
unserer Seite über die Zeit hinweg
unterschiedliche Handlungen bei dem
Gegner provozieren das wäre dann quasi
diese tiefen Staffelung und das
kennzeichnet künstliche Intelligenz der
dritten Welle und genau das wird für
war Gaming auch genutzt weil man hiermit
natürlich unterschiedliche Samsung
strategische operative Abfolgen sehr gut
simulieren kann und eben nicht nur zu
einem Zeitpunkt sondern über mehrere
entscheidungsfrequenzen Tage Wochen
hinweg wenn man einfach die Simulation
lange genug laufen lässt mit anderen
Worten ja es sind
entscheidungsunterstützungssysteme sie
können aber auch in der konkreten
Entscheidungssituation auf dem Kampffeld
genutzt werden dann lassen Sie uns ein
bisschen über Gefahren sprechen hier
fragt ein User ist es nicht nur eine
Frage der Zeit bis strukturell
problematische Staaten gnadenlose
ki-kriegswaffen einsetzen und wie können
die angegriffenen dann noch gut werhaft
sein also die Frage die grundsätzlich ja
dahinter steht ist die Gefahr eines
Wettrüstens gegeben durch KI
ähm meine Antwort lautete vorhin wer KI
nicht nutzt verliert wer KI nutzt wird
nicht zwangsläufig gewinnen aber er hat
bessere Chancen insofern sind wir
natürlich in einem Wettrüsten in Bezug
auf die Frage der
Weiterentwicklung von KI und der
Implementation von KI wichtig ist aber
KI selber und alleine ist nicht
kriegsentscheidend wenn wir uns die
Ukraine anschauen sehen wir es geht auch
um die Verfügbarkeit von wirkungsmitteln
Munition zum Beispiel und es geht um das
was wir in ghostplay Ökosystemen nennen
das heißt künstliche Intelligenz
benötigt Sensordaten künstliche
Intelligenz benötigt das Zusammenführen
von Sensordaten benötigt sozusagen dann
auch die Verbindung zu den Soldaten die
dann vor Ort sich bewegen müssen oder zu
entsprechenden wirkungsmitteln und oder
zu Radar es ist also letzten Endes ein
Baustein in einem sehr komplexen System
das nur wenn es sozusagen komplex und
systemisch gedacht wird wirklich
wirkungsüberlegenheiten dass die
Bundeswehr erzielen kann also KI alleine
ist kein gamechanger aber KI in einem
Ökosystem das entsprechend aufgebaut
wird kann zu wirkungsüberlegenheit
führen ein Wort möchte ich gerne aus was
hington mit zu Ihnen bringen nach
Hamburg nämlich dass das
robotergenerals wie weit sind wir denn
hier in Deutschland von so etwas
entfernt
in Deutschland sind wir komplett weit
also in der Bundeswehr sind hier
komplett weiter von entfernt bei
vollkommen klar ist dass die
Verantwortung bei einem Menschen liegen
muss wir haben KI
entscheidungsunterstützungssysteme die
werden auch in Zukunft wichtiger werden
und diese KI
entscheidungsunterstützungssysteme
leisten das was vorhin aus Washington
berichtet wurde nämlich Daten so schnell
aufzuarbeiten dass man dann als Mensch
mehr Zeit hat um informierte ethisch
moralisch informierte Entscheidungen zu
treffen insofern kann KI genau das
Gegenteil von dem bringen was manche
Kritiker befürchten nämlich Zeit
gewinnen damit man den Menschen wieder
reinbringen kann in dieser oder oder ähm
also es ist ein ambivalenter Prozess in
Bezug auf die Frage was machen wir mit
Waffen die so schnell sind dass man als
Mensch wieso keine Chance mehr hätte
darauf zu reagieren das sind nur eine
bestimmte Anzahl von Waffen sind super
schallwaffen bei dem man ganz sicher
entsprechen
automatisierte Systeme braucht bei denen
aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit von
Kollateralschäden ausgesprochen gering
ist wir haben es damit anderen
wirkmitteln zu tun Drohnen oder
ähnliches die zum Beispiel in Gebieten
im Einsatz sind in denen es Zivilisten
gibt oder ähnliches dort sind
potenzielle konzentralschäden so groß
dass man sich natürlich Sorgen machen
muss darüber ob man dort solche Systeme
in welchem Autonomie gerade eingesetzt
werden will also mein Vorschlag wir
schauen was sind die konkreten sozusagen
Nutzungsszenarien und nehmen dann von
dort aus so Risiken Matrixen
Berechnungen vor und von dort aus weiter
zu kommen
dann lassen Sie uns bei dem Beispiel der
Drohnen gerade mal bleiben wir haben
einen Blick darauf geworfen welche Rolle
künstliche Intelligenz in Zusammenhang
mit Drohnen spielen kann und das schauen
wir uns gemeinsam an
schon seit einiger Zeit haben Hersteller
ihr Verteidigungs Arsenal an die
Bedrohung angepasst so genannte Jammer
unterbrechen die elektronische Steuerung
ein gezielter Schuss mit speziellen
Gewehren das war's
Schwärme und größere Drohnen werden per
Radar und optischer Aufklärung erfasst
künstliche Intelligenz analysiert per
Mustererkennung anfliegende Objekte in
Sekundenbruchteilen
Mantis etwa ein Flugabwehrsystem der
Bundeswehr feuertausend Schuss in der
Minute ab und berechnet in Millisekunden
wann die intelligente Munition vor dem
Eindringling am effektivsten explodiert
kurz vor dem Ziel setzt die Granate
unzählige Splitter frei ein Durchkommen
unmöglich
die Abwehrwaffe der Zukunft ist schon in
der Erprobung ebenfalls per KI
unterstützt entscheiden
laserstrahlkanonen welches Ziel Sie
zuerst und dann gemeinsam attackieren
Vorteil Abwehr also wohl kaum denn auch
die drohnenentwicklung geht weiter mit
mehr KI und Materialeinsatz
[Musik]
ja Herr Professor Schall wir haben die
Drohnen gerade gesehen und die
Möglichkeiten die künstliche Intelligenz
bietet lassen Sie uns bei dem bei dem
Beispiel gerade bleiben mit dem Drohnen
Angriff ich habe eine Situation die gab
es im Afghanistan Krieg die gibt es
jetzt in der Ukraine eine Gruppe von
Zivilisten ist in einem Supermarkt oder
in einem Restaurant und möglicherweise
sind dort auch feindliche Soldaten
was ist wie zu entscheiden wie würde der
Mensch entscheiden und wie entscheidet
die Drohne und nach welchen ethischen
Kriterien entscheidet die Drohne
wie vorhin schon gesagt es ist eine
Frage der jetzt sage ich doch mal
Programmierung ja es gibt es gibt ein i
Triple e Standard eine internationale
Standardisierungsorganisation für für
technologiebasierte Entwicklung die
beschäftigt sich tatsächlich mit Ethik
in autonomen Systemen und das ist halt
die zwei Triple
e72021 und hier fragt man sich wie
können wir es schaffen ethische
Überlegungen in die sozusagen in den Bau
und in die
Programmierung sage ich doch mal von von
KI z.B in Drohnen hinein zu bekommen das
heißt man probiert so etwas ähnliches
umzusetzen wie Ethik beides sein man
probiert das was wir wollen bereits in
die Programmierung in den sozusagen das
handlungsreport war von Drohnen zu
bekommen und damit die an das anzupassen
was unsere ethischen Standard sagen wir
kurz auf Engagement der NATO sind und
das wäre eine Möglichkeit dafür
Professor Schall darf ich da kurz
einhaken denn das Problem der Menschheit
besteht ja unter anderem darin dass wir
diese Fragen diskutieren aber gar keine
richtigen Antworten darauf haben also
die Frage ist es moralisch ein Flugzeug
abzuschießen wenn die Insassen dabei
sterben aber dafür werden sich tausende
Menschen in einem Fußballstadion
gerettet diese Fragen stellen wir uns
aber wir haben keine umfassende Antwort
darauf wie sollen wir denn die KI
füttern wenn wir selber nicht wissen
und jetzt stelle ich Ihnen die Frage und
allen anderen auch welchen moralischen
Zwängen und drucken denn tatsächlich
militärische Entscheider ausgesetzt sind
die in solchen Augenblicken entscheiden
müssen also letzten Endes wir
externalisieren das was wir als
Gesellschaft in Bezug auf unsere Ethik
nicht konsensual Wissen auf diejenigen
die unter Entscheidungszwang in einer
entsprechenden militärischen Situation
stehen und die Diskussion über
künstliche Intelligenz macht genau 1 sie
zeigt uns auf wo wir als Gesellschaft
stehen und wofür wir stehen und dass wir
kein Konsens in diesen Fragen haben
zeigt einfach nur dass wir uns teilweise
vor der ethischen Frage drücken was uns
wie viel wert ist sei sozusagen in einem
zehntelverhältnis oder einfach bloß
tatsächlich als intrinsischer Wert und
wenn wir genötigt sind das was wir
Menschen intuitiv tun oder mit sowas
ähnlich wie ein einer moralischen
Intuition tatsächlich zu formalisieren
fällt es uns unglaublich schwer genau
das zu tun und insofern haben wir es
nicht mit einem Problem der künstlichen
Intelligenz zu tun sondern mit einem
Problem das eigentlich vorgelagert ist
die Frage was sind unsere wirklichen
ethischen Standards und eine Antwort
lautet
das Minimum der Ethik ist das Recht und
das wäre für mich die Genfer Konvention
ein etwas auf das sich alle berufen
können eine total spannende Frage in
diesem Zusammenhang kommt an dieser
Stelle von Sven Odendahl über Facebook
werden in einem solchen Szenario auch
mögliche Szenarien zur Friedenslösung
durch die KI mit berücksichtigt und das
ist natürlich insofern spannend weil
natürlich kann man die KI programmieren
dass sie möglichst effizient Krieg führt
aber der Mensch entscheidet ja an
irgendeinem Punkt jetzt ist gerade der
richtige Zeitpunkt um zu verhandeln
können wir auch nach der KI beibringen
es gibt ja es gibt ja
weltsimulationsprogramme selbst
weltsimulationski quasi nicht nur das
militärische Battlefield betrachten
sondern in einem globalen systemischen
Ansatz unterwegs sind so etwas wäre es
wenn man es dann wollte in dem Bereich
in dem ich unterwegs bin also dem
engeren sozusagen verteidigungs- ist
diese Frage nicht wirklich angekommen
ich hätte aber eine andere Deutung
nämlich auf Basis unserer eigenen
Forschung haben wir
sagen wir mal zehn Panzer und wir haben
getestet wie viel Drohnen es braucht von
einem roten Team also einem Gegner um
diese Panzer aus zu löschen
einmal mit und einmal ohne unsere
künstliche Intelligenz Ergebnis war man
braucht ungefähr sechs Mal so viel
Drohnen wenn man künstliche Intelligenz
sozusagen erhöhte Ausrüstung hat als
normale mit menschlichen Entscheidung
und meine Antwort lautet dass wir mit
Hilfe von künstlichen Intelligenz und
dem was wir in Deutschland zum Beispiel
an wirkmitteln haben wenn man die
updatet erhöht man die
Abschreckungswirkung dessen was da ist
teilweise in den Faktor drei vier fünf
sechs und das bedeutet dass wir nicht in
eine hochrüstungsspirale kommen und
trotzdem mehr Abschreckung haben und das
wäre für mich schon mal eine Annäherung
daran dass es gar nicht erst zu einem
Krieg kommt ich weiß das ist keine so
schöne Lösung wie die die gefragt wurde
auf Facebook was glaube ich aber es ist
zum eine praktikable Möglichkeit für die
politische Praxis
lassen Sie uns noch über ein Beispiel
denken sprechen was schon selbst relativ
viel entscheidet oder mit entscheidet
wenn man das so sagen kann nämlich harpy
können Sie ganz kurz erklären was das
ist und wie das funktioniert
auf dieses Beispiel würde ich gerne in
diesem Augenblick lieber nicht eingehen
dann hacke ich jetzt auch nicht nach
aber vielleicht können Sie den
ZuschauerInnen und zuschauernden zwei
Sätzen nur erklären warum sie darauf
nicht eingehen möchten denn das ist ja
man kann dafür gute Gründe haben aber
vielleicht ist es gut zu wissen warum
das hat so ein bisschen damit zu tun wer
wir sind ja sozusagen im Bereich des
Bundesministeriums der Verteidigung und
zum anderen dass wir natürlich auch
Industriekontakte haben es gibt
bestimmte Bereiche in denen ich dann
einfach lieber keine Stellungnahme geben
würde es gibt Bereiche die sind es gibt
Bereiche die sind nicht für die
öffentlichkeit ähm bestimmt vielleicht
können Sie ja aber weil das einen User
auch interessiert ohne dass sie da jetzt
irgendwie zu weit gehen aber vielleicht
können Sie die Frage beantworten hier
fragt jemand wie viel KI entwickelt die
Bundeswehr selber und was macht die
Rüstungsindustrie zum Beispiel Helsing
oder rein Metall wem gehört das KI
Modell dann der Bundeswehr oder dem
Unternehmen
okay das ist eine Frage die ich einfach
beantworten kann die kann ich nun darf
ich auch beantworten
alle alle deutschen Rüstungsunternehmen
Arbeiten an ki-modellen natürlich
Helsing natürlich reinmetall und ähnlich
ist sie sind sehr avanciert und das
Problem ist die Frage nach der sozusagen
Transparenz der KI weil das die KI
Modelle sind ja dann tatsächlich Teil
des Business Plans gehören also in ihrer
in ihrer in ihrer Programmierung und
ähnlichen dementsprechenden Unternehmen
das kann für
Irritationen sorgen und auch für
sicherheitspolitische Herausforderungen
deshalb gibt es einige Überlegungen die
dahin gehen dass man so etwas ähnliches
hat wie KI Modelle die komplett gekauft
werden und dann von der Bundeswehr von
unseren eigenen Programmierern und
IT-Spezialisten angepasst werden so dass
wir quasi dann eigene inhouse Lösungen
haben die auch genuin schließlich von
der Bundeswehr genutzt werden das hat
vor und Nachteile es hat den Nachteil
dass man mehr Ressourcen braucht es hat
den Vorteil dass dass man dann erst mit
sozusagen singulären Systemen zu tun hat
denn eine Gefahr die vorhin auch genannt
wurde ist sobald man weiß wie unsere
entscheidungssysteme funktionieren es
muss nicht gehackt werden muss sozusagen
muss
entscheidungsalgorithmen kennen weiß man
wie wir reagieren werden und damit sind
Überraschungsmomente weg weil man ja
berechenbar wird und das wäre die größte
Katastrophe und hier haben wir es also
mit einem mit einem sozusagen
mit einer Balance zu tun zwischen
unterschiedlichen Zielen die man im
Augenblick noch in der Diskussion hat
wofür kann ich sagen ja das war doch das
war doch schon sehr viel vielen
herzlichen Dank dafür eine Frage noch
wir haben zu Beginn der Sendung in die
Ukraine geblickt das würde ich jetzt
gegen Ende der Sendung gerne auch noch
mal tun
inwiefern profitiert die Ukraine konkret
von künstlicher Intelligenz was die
Munition angeht sie haben das schon mal
angerissen aber vielleicht können wir es
noch mal kurz vertiefen
Munition ist ja eines der ganz großen
sozusagen Lieferprobleme für die Ukraine
und
die Ukraine hat in den letzten Monaten
feuerleitsysteme bekommen die KI basiert
sind und diese feuerleitssysteme die KI
basiert sind erhöhen die Zielgenauigkeit
und reduzieren auch die Zeit zwischen
sozusagen den Befehl dass man sich auf
etwas fokussiert im Abschluss und
dementsprechend ist die Nutzung der
knappen Ressourcen Munition deutlich
besser geworden also mit anderen Worten
hier hat die Ukraine deutlich profitiert
davon dass sie KI in diesem
feuerlandssystem hat
eine Frage zum Abschluss über Facebook
fragt Wolfgang Müller oder sagt er
Menschen die sowas erfinden sind hoch
gefährlich und er selbst sagt ich halte
KI für sehr gefährlich die Frage an Sie
ist KI beim militärischen Einsatz
gefährlich oder
macht es Krieg so weit man das überhaupt
sagen kann
besser weil man damit weniger zivile
Ziele
Mitleidenschaft sieht weil weniger
Menschen sterben weil die Soldaten
besser geschützt werden weil Munition
effizienter eingesetzt wird macht KI
Kriege besser wenn es denn überhaupt
Kriege geben muss
alle Punkte die sie genannt haben
sprechen dafür dass man künstliche
Intelligenz einsetzt wenn es tatsächlich
zu einem heißen Krieg kommt
hundertprozentig
dass die größte Herausforderung für mich
besteht darin dass das passiert was die
NATO bereits 2022 immer drin gesagt hat
nämlich dass wir gar nicht mehr zwischen
Krieg und Frieden differenzieren weil
wir uns in einem permanenten Zustand
einen braustufen Zustand befinden indem
wir Hybrid angegriffen werden
insbesondere im Bereich der
Desinformation der hybriden des
Information oder das was man kommt
vorfährt nennen kann also die
Beeinflussung unserer
meinungsöffentlichkeit mit dem
dezidierten Ziel unsere Demokratie zu
destabilisieren unsere außenpolitischen
Entscheidungen zu verändern und letzten
Endes damit die demokratische Qualität
und das Leben hier weniger sichert zu
machen und weniger freiheitlich und das
ist die größte Herausforderung für mich
dass wir uns eigentlich in ein Zustand
sozusagen Chris angegriffen Seins
befinden ohne dass wir als Gesellschaft
wirklich ein Bewusstsein dafür haben wo
wir überall potenziell manipuliert
werden auf der anderen Seite könnte auch
das Gefühl immer aufmerksam sein zu
müssen für die Fakes in Audio im
Videobereich oder ähnliches ich könnte
die ganze Zeit sozusagen in russischer
Troll sein ja der hier eingespeist wird
wir können so keine Demokratie führen
das heißt wir müssen grundlegend anders
denken wie man vor dem Hintergrund von
Meinungsmanipulation und der Nutzung von
künstlichen Intelligenz durch
gegnerische Staaten autokratische Natur
Demokratie anders denkt dass sie
resilienter wird also mit anderen Worten
wir müssen die Art wie wir unsere
Demokratie denken neu denken und das
werden wir quasi angegriffen werden und
das macht für mich die größte
Herausforderung aus der Krieg ist nicht
nur in der Ukraine die Reparationen sind
dauerhaft auch in unserer Gesellschaft
eine große Herausforderung für uns alle
für die ganze Welt vielen Dank Herr
Professor Schall dass Sie bei uns in der
Sendung waren und so viele Fragen von
unseren Userin und Usern beantwortet
haben und ähm danke schön dafür dass sie
hier waren herzlichen Dank das hat mich
sehr gefreut danke für die tollen fragen